submarines a bit chilly today team hats  on it's important to have a good support  system to see my grandfather Jacques  Cousteau knew how valuable friends were  beautiful specimens aren't they  I've got a pistol shrimp and goby fish  in this bag these two are in a  mutualistic symbiotic relationship which  means they depend on each other for  survival here's how it works the pistol  shrimp is an amazing digger but nearly  blind  the goby fish likes living in ocean  floor tunnels but can't dig the goby has  great eyesight the shrimp has a great  digging claw they're a perfect match  these two pair up and is the shrimp digs  the goby keeps watch for predators once  they pair they're inseparable and that's  the deal the goby gets a home and the  shrimp gets a seeing-eye fish scientists  aren't sure how these two find each  other in the first place it could be a  chemical or an optical attraction either  way it's a beautiful thing